these are wigar workers featured on
chinese state media
celebrating the islamic festival of eid
al-adha
they are not in xinjiang their home but
thousands of miles away
in shandong east china rights groups
allege that sending uighurs to factories
around the country is indicative of
forced
labor that they are subject to strict
controls as part of a policy of
assimilation
china rejects those claims but sky news
has uncovered evidence of the tight
social and political controls applied to
weak workers
on the chinese internet there are
hundreds of postings offering uighur
labor
in batches of 50 to 100 people this one
says that the security of workers will
be guaranteed by the government
the company hosting the adverts did not
respond to a request for comment
we phoned some of the numbers listed
[Music]
ultimately the government decides where
workers go another agent told us
when they get that government approval
the workers end up in factories like the
one in the video
we went to shandong to find out more
when we arrived at the seafood
processing factory
it was a very different scene there are
no uyghurs here
the factory owner told us they've all
returned home because of the pandemic
he described the idea of forced labor as
nonsense saying workers came here
because they chose to
earned at least 300 pounds per month and
had air conditioners in their on-site
dormitories
but they were under close supervision
the cctv cameras in the office monitor
those dormitories
riot control gear is also at hand and if
workers wish to leave the factory to go
shopping the owner told us
the company would drive them into buses
in the meantime he had called the police
12 officers and communist party
officials questioned us for two hours
before ordering us to leave town our
questions were not welcome at another
seafood factory in the same province
for years it has run a uk subsidiary
registered in london
this manager was waiting at the door he
told us bluntly there were no
wiga workers here nor had there been in
the several years he had been employed
at the factory
that's contradicted by photos posted in
march last year on the company's website
which have since been deleted it shows
uyga workers arriving from xinjiang
the accompanying announcement says that
their arrival will help poverty
alleviation
and the integration of the national
family this is a coastal
export city some two thousand miles away
from landlocked xinjiang it comes with a
very different
way of life uighur workers are being
sent all across
china to different cities at the very
least it is a
vast labor transfer program and it's one
that requires a whole industry
around it the chinese government has
been mounting an aggressive publicity
campaign
in reaction to the allegations of forced
labour
we were invited to this press conference
in beijing earlier this year
questions had to be pre-submitted in
order to attend
we were told this uyghur man had taken
part in the labor transfer program
if this labor isn't worth if it is
enforced why do they need government
supervision
[Music]
sky news asked the chinese government
for a response to our story
but after a week had received no reply
even here in east china so far away from
xinjiang
answers are hard to find